what stands out to you about the way
your team played tonight uh we just
played hard we communicated on both ends
got good shots and you know we're really
T the team and we just went out there
and showed it tonight six steals for you
tonight what do you love so much about
the way competing on defense wait pardon
say again what do you love about
competing on defense with those six
steals tonight just making plays flying
around making stuff happen 26 points for
you you have fit so well into this
system plus 38 tonight What can you say
about your teammates in terms of why
this has been such a fit oh just them
encouraging me to be aggressive and uh
just play hard and make winning plays we
all try to do the same thing so it helps
out a lot you knock off the defending
champs what's important about these
signature signature type of wins
throughout the regular season uh just uh
we're playing a great team you want to
go out there and you know do your best
and we went out there and did it tonight
for sure thanks o thank you